vielleicht nur sagen es liegt keine
einzige hochschule veröffentlicht
europas präsentiert sich hier nahezu 20
nationen verändert geht die fluggeräte
beratern zwei tagen voraus bis zu
300.000 physik das ist natürlich ein
wesentliches der ungefähre können unsere
jungs kompetenzen können sie vielleicht
erreichen wir demonstrieren nahrung es
geht um die aktion zu machen sei es auch
darum es geht um die katastrophenhilfe
ein großer werbeeffekt gefangen hat für
das österreichische bundesheer
hierbei den hubschrauber c 212 40
besucher natürlich besonders für das
line up des 14 effekten fünf jahren
durchgeführt
juli des jahres
jetzt muss italien überstellt und wir
haben also die flotte komplett
modifiziert und daher verpflichtet sind
die vor allem natürlich für das gas kopf
wie für die selbstschussanlage diversen
geworden
bestmöglich für die auslandseinsätze
dieser bug sowohl den sehen die wir hier
vorfinden ist sensationell was zu tun
ist aber ein gutes mittel
grundlegende elemente des fliegens start
zu stehen wenn diese partie 100
vier personen käme und
die punkte
unter anleitung von ausgebildeten
wie es hieß